bonjour à tous je sais que ça fait un
moment qu'on ne s'est pas vu mais je
reprends définitivement du service pour
un épisode cours en attendant le gros
épisode en préparation et qui devrait
sortir dans pas très longtemps et je
profite du contexte dans lequel on
baigne en ce moment pour revenir un
petit peu sur la sociologie du vote
[Musique]
alors je ne vais pas détailler tous les
travaux en cours sur le sujet parce que
ce serait beaucoup trop long mais je
vais plutôt revenir sur une pratique une
façon de présenter les résultats des
élections qu'on a l'habitude de voir et
qui pourraient nous paraître évidente
mais qui est en fait historiquement et
socialement construite et cette façon de
présenter c'est tout simplement la carte
électorale
aujourd'hui on est très habitué à ça on
l'a vu au lendemain du premier tour des
présidentielles il y avait en jeunes les
départements pour macron en gris pour le
fn en bleu pour les républicains et en
rouge pour jean luc mélenchon est bien
le fait d'envisager les comportements
électoraux comme géographiquement situés
ne va en fait pas de soi il est issu du
modèle géographiques où on dit aussi le
modèle écologique d'explication du vote
c'est un modèle que l'on doit un certain
andré siegfried dans son ouvrage de 1913
tableau politique de la france de
l'ouest sous la troisième république
alors siegfried y les historiens
géographes sociologues
il est engagé en politique auprès des
radicaux de gauche et il aimerait bien
lui aussi être un homme politique mais
il n'arrivera jamais à se faire élire
député il échouera à quatre reprises aux
élections de 1902 1903 1906 et 1910 donc
c'est un peu la loose quoi mais
finalement ces échecs seront bénéfiques
pour la science parce qu'il va prendre
du recul sur sa situation et se dire
qu'à cela ne tienne je vais essayer de
comprendre pourquoi je me suis fait beau
lot c'est comme ça je m'enlève pas
complètement sur l'exactitude historique
de la citation mais en termes de sens et
s attend à partir de là il va faire un
gros travail de terrain si l'on enquête
dans 14 départements de l'ouest de la
france
il observe la physionomie géographiques
et politiques de la région et ils
étudient notamment les résultats
électoraux entre 1870 et 1910 et de ses
analyses il tire la conclusion que le
vote est déterminé par quatre variables
qui jouent en cascade
premièrement la nature des sols qui va
elle-même influer sur la structure de
l'habitat qui va elle même influer sur
la structure de la propriété foncière et
tout ça va se retrouver dans les
relations sociales qui seront à terme un
facteur explicatif du vote
alors je vous expliquer tout ça c'est
vrai que quand on voit ça on comprend
pas forcément comment ça peut être un
modèle explicatif du vote
mais c'est pas difficile à comprendre il
va prendre l'exemple de l'avant dès
qu'ils les utilisent comme un idéal type
c'est vrai que je vous ai pas encore
expliquer ce que c'était qu'un idéal
type et ça va venir pour aujourd'hui on
peut simplement considérer que c'est un
très bon exemple du modèle qu'il essaye
de prouver ce qu'il explique
c'est que la vendée elle est séparée
entre le nord et le sud
dans le nord il ya du granit donc c'est
une roche imperméable
donc il ya de multiples points d'eau
comme il ya plein de points d'eau
différents les installations agricoles
sont très espacées et comme elles sont
très espacées ça veut dire qu'il ya de
très grandes propriétés foncières ainsi
la population elle est rural elle est
isolée puisque naples 1 2 pts 6 et elle
subit à la fois l'influencé très forte
de l'église et aussi des notables les
notables qui sont les fameux
propriétaires fonciers et du coup de
fait de ces deux influences là qui sont
plutôt conservatrice on va retrouver au
nord un vote plutôt conservateur
al'inverse au sud la roche et en
calcaire c'est une roche perméable comme
elle est perméable elle ne laisse pas
passer l'eau donc il ya très peu de
points d'eau comme il ya peu de points
d'eau les installations agricoles sont
regroupés en petits groupes sur de
petites propriétés foncières comme les
installations sont regroupés les
populations rurales elles ne sont pas
isolées elles sont solidaires et elle
arrive mieux à résister à la fois l
influence de l'église est à la fois
l'influencé des propriétaires fonciers
ce qui fait qu'ils ont naturellement à
votre plus progressistes donc un vote
républicain pour l'époque et du coup sa
fameuse conclusion que restée célèbre
par la suite c'est le granit vote à
droite le calcaire vote à gauche
bon en fait s'il a tellement insisté sur
la vendée c'est parce que son modèle il
marchait pas du tout dans les autres
régions de la france
ça marchait vraiment que pour la vendée
mais les explications qu'il avançait en
termes d'évolution historique des
rapports sociaux étaient une bonne
explication et marchaient assez bien
pour expliquer les tenants du vote en
vendée à l'heure où il faisait son étude
et d'ailleurs ce qui est très
intéressant c'est de constater que cette
opposition entre nord et sud et gauche
et droite pour la vendée marche encore
aujourd'hui enfin non ça marchait encore
en 2012
si on regarde les résultats aux
législatives en 2012 on voit en effet
que le clivage nord-sud droite ps est
toujours d'actualité
si je regarde en 2017 et que je me fie
aux candidats arrivés en tête au premier
tour la carte ça donnerait plutôt ça
c'est à dire une majorité modène en
marche
du coup ça nous permet au moins de voir
que les élections de 2017 or ont rebattu
les cartes pour ce qui est de
l'identification politique puisque des
votes historiques ont été remis en
question qu'on le partage que je droite
de la vendée alors cette sociologie
géographique est toujours d'actualité
aujourd'hui il ya de nombreux
sociologues qui travaillent encore à
partir de cette technique là on peut par
exemple citer hervé le bras qui dans les
années 90 proposait une méthode
quasiment mathématiques pour expliquer
le vote fn en disant qu'on pouvait
quasiment faire une équation en
disons qu'on avait de plus en plus de
probabilités de voter fn en fonction du
nombre d'immigrés qu'il y avait sur le
territoire français c'est des résultats
qui ont été par la suite affiné
notamment à l'aide de la cartographie si
c'est vrai au niveau macro la sociologie
géographique permet d'affiner l'analyse
si on regarde sur la région parisienne
par exemple on voit que le vote fn n'est
pas particulièrement présents là où il
ya beaucoup d'immigrés
mais là où il y en a au contraire peu
mais suffisamment proche pour se sentir
menacé en bref on a peur de ce qu'on ne
connaît pas mais qui est quand même pas
trop loin de façon à ce que ça puisse
quand même constituer une menace alors
plus récemment est levé le bras a
proposé une nouvelle analyse du vote fn
en montrant qu'on peut en fait quasiment
superposer la carte des inégalités et la
carte du vote fn en france
de fait on remarque que c'est dans les
régions où il ya le plus d'inégalités
qu'on retrouve également le plus grand
nombre d'électeurs fn
alors si le sujet vous intéresse je vous
invite à regarder la vidéo deux ont
causé sur le sujet où il essaye
justement d'essayer de mieux comprendre
les déterminants du vote fn à partir de
ce type d analyse quant à moi ce sera
tout pour aujourd'hui j'espère que la
vidéo vous a plu et je vous dis à très
vite pour une prochaine vidéo